though we're trying to get some can you
see if we can get in the papers
i'm trying to get could i could i listen
ben affleck and jennifer lopez's reunion
has been a gift
and now we know who to thank i think we
had chemistry
as actors from the first moment we
started working a source tells e.t
that affleck was the one who made the
first move which then led to their
romantic rekindling
the source says ben has always had an
affinity for jennifer
and was the one who initially started
pursuing her and making an effort to
reconnect
romantically speaking he wanted to
explore things with her beyond a
friendship
and they've both really been enjoying
spending time together
these new details follow sightings of
the pair in montana together over the
weekend
after affleck was previously spotted
multiple times at her los
angeles home we're gonna give it away
but it has a very good ending
affleck and lopez began dating in 2002
quickly followed by the couple
announcing their engagement
but in 2003 the wedding was called off
just days before their planned ceremony
in september
they officially called off the
engagement in january 2004
but remained on friendly terms following
the split we were about to get married
it didn't work out and it was just a bad
heartbreak
like you know just one of those breakups
that really you know
it was like a tough one for me for
whatever reason
so should we be shocked by this reunion
maybe not
according to those in their inner
circles another source previously told
et
it wasn't a huge surprise to their
friends who knew they had stayed in
touch over the years
the source added ben is protective over
j-lo and they're trying to be
as low-key as possible we like we need
to control that
i don't know how that happened and this
resurgence arrives not too long after
affleck went to bat for his ex
calling out the vicious response to
their past relationship there's always a
story of the month me dating jennifer
lopez happened to be that tabloid story
at the time when
that business grew exponentially in
january the 48 year old actor appeared
on the hollywood reporters award chatter
podcast
where he didn't mince words for critics
of their early 2000s romance
at first it was like dick and liz it was
this sort of infatuation
what an interesting couple and then
there was a ton of resentment a ton of
resentment against me a ton of
resentment against jennifer
people were so [ __ ] mean about her
sexist racist you know ugly
vicious it was written about her in ways
that
if you wrote it now you would literally
be fired you're saying
you said affleck also highlighted the
brighter side of this story in the years
since
the overwhelming praise lopez has
received for her wide-ranging career
now it's like she's lionized and
respected
for the work she did where she came from
what she accomplished as well she
should
[Music]
you